for
[Music]
know he was on
hello hello can you can you hear me yes
oh
sorry hello come on in come on in
everybody so happy to see you so glad
you're
here um my name is Rachel my pronouns
are she her um and I'm just so excited
that you're here with us today I have a
few quick announcements for you um first
on November 17th right after service
we're going to be having a chili cook
off um and celebrating our 5year
anniversary as a church uh so put that
on your calendars and get your favorite
chili recipe ready um next uh not your
mama Sunday school is coming back uh
this fall meetup group will be October
27th through November 24th um it's a 1
and a half hour per week class um if you
are deconstructing or you're wrestling
with scripture trying to figure out what
you believe about things this is the
place for you um that will be October
27th through November 24th starting at
300 p.m. we'll be reading through the
gospel of Mark um and then a reminder
that the centerpiece conference for
lgbtq plus Christians and allies is this
week uh October 24th through 26 and we'd
love to see you there um you can scan
the QR code to get tickets if you'd like
to all right um now we're going to exit
the kingdom of noise and productivity
and hurry
and we're going to enter into the
kingdom of Silence Stillness and
simplicity a Sacred
Space a place for prayer worship and
adoration a place to behold Christ
revelation of God and heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you and to mend your heart
may we all come home
thank you would you guys go ahead and
stand with us we're going to get started
with a song called heavy so you guys can
clap along if you want follow Jesse
[Music]
if you're lost in your
lonely go on and figure out why take
your trip to your dark side go on and
have a good
cry cuz we're all
lonely we're all lonely
[Music]
together I want to see your
sness I want to share your sins I want
to bleed your blood and I want to be let
in don't you just don't we all just want
to be
[Music]
together leave what's heavy
leave what's
heavy what's heavy
behind what's
[Music]
heavy what's heavy
behind if your face is down
take a look
[Music]
around do your fingers move do your
lungs are you tired are you weary of the
Hidden You' been
[Music]
holding did you live that love or have
you never hied all you feeling St
because you did a bad
thing hey
[Applause]
[Music]
heavy what heavy
high was
Heavy what heavy behind
[Music]
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feel in fearful
sister the only way to l
that fearful feeling replace it with
love that's
[Music]
healing are you feeling fearful brother
are you feeling fearful
sister
be
what what tell me behind
[Music]
what's
heavy what's heavy
behind what
behind
leave what's
[Music]
heavy what
heavy
[Music]
behind all right kiddos y'all are
dismissed to go to your classrooms your
teachers will meet you over by the
doors so good to see y'all here have fun
Love on those teachers for us
[Music]
as they make their way out we're going
to move into um what we call the prayers
of the people so if this is your first
time here with us this is a tradition
back through Christian history it's a
prayer that we share in recognizing that
we're all carrying different loads into
this space together different things on
our hearts and we just want to
acknowledge and make room for those as a
community and we want to hold those
before God together so you can follow
along the parts that are in red read
those aloud and then in the middle of
the prayer we'll take space for you to
name what you might be caring um and
then we'll close the prayer together at
the
end Jesus for the city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to
[Music]
you with us
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
[Music]
I'll never be more Lov than I am right
now wasn't holding you up so there's
nothing I can do to let you
down it doesn't take a trophy
to make you
proud and I'll never be more love I am
[Music]
right down I hear your voice carried in
the RM of the wind
me you would cross an ocean so I would
in you never closer than
you
J you are
[Music]
now you
are and I will be
content in every
circumstance you are
you are
enough forever enough always enough more
than enough you forever enough is enough
more than
enough I don't want to
forget how I feel right now on the
mountain
top I can see so clear what it's all
about so stay by my side when the Sun
goes
down don't want to forget how I feel
right
now you
are you
are you are
and I will be
cont in every
[Music]
circumstance you are
enough forever enough always enough more
than
enough forever enough always enough
[Music]
I'm
already I'm
already I know who I
am I know what you've
spoken I'm
already more than I can imagine
let's sing that together I'm already
love I'm already
CH I know who I
am I know what you
spoken I'm already
love than I can
imagine that is enough
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm
already already
chosen I know who I
am I know what you
broken I'm already
love more than I could
imagine that is enough
[Applause]
[Music]
is that is
enough that is
[Music]
you
are
[Music]
will in every circum
you
[Music]
are yes
God you are
anchor you are our home
[Music]
in my mother's
womb you formed me with your hands known
in Love by
you before I took a breath when I
doubted Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully me you're an artist and a
part I'm the king
in the
CL you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your glory
glory and for your
[Music]
name and there's a healing
light just beyond the clouds though I've
walked through fire
I see clearly now I know nothing has
been wasted no fail or mistake you're an
arst and
depart the CH
and you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good
you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name you make all
things work
together together for my
future and for my good you make all
things
work
together for your
glory and for your
[Music]
name when I doubt it Lord remind me I'm
one fully made you're an artist and a
part I'm the C and the clay and I know
nothing has been wasted no failure or
mistake you're an artist and
a I'm the C and the clay when I doubt it
Lord remind me I'm wonderfully made
you're an artist and the part I'm the C
and the clay and I know nothing has been
wasted no failure or mistake you're an
artist and the father I'm the
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me you're not finished
with me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me yet you're not finished
with me no you're not finished with me
yet you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
the work
[Applause]
together for your
glory and for your name and when I doubt
it Lord my
I'm wonderfully made you're in AR and
the part the C and the clay and I know
nothing has been wasted no failure
Lord you're in arst and the part the C
and the CL
[Music]
you make all
things work
together for my future
and for my goody make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your
[Music]
name yes would that be hope that we hold
on to tonight God
that even when we can't see the end we
can't see where the path is
leading even when we're searching around
in the
dark God that you are still
working you are still with
us your spirit is still
moving God would we trust that you are
going to do a good work in and through
our
lives would we trust that you are the
author and the perfector of our faith
and you don't give up on your
creation you don't set it
aside you don't leave it
behind but you continue to offer love
and light and
hope healing and
transformation God would we allow that
good work to happen in our
hearts would you take root in our
[Music]
lives it's in your name that we ask all
these things tonight
Jesus
amen all right would you guys turn to
the people around you say hello and make
them feel welcome
oh Grace and
peace it is so good to be with you my
name is Brett pronouns he him and yeah
it's a joy a joy to welcome you into
this space and as always that includes
those joining joining us online love
youall lots and don't forget to grab
your communion supplies now for later in
the service and uh anyone here tonight
who is new thank you for for being Among
Us um we're really really glad that
you're here and and hope you just I
don't know feel a s of of Christ's love
and welcome in this space so um we are
in part two in our series titled Jesus
and
politics and I'm drawing on uh two books
in particular um to help guide my
reading and interpreting I want to
mention these each week um just to kind
of keep them out there before you for
any anyone that uh feels uh you know
inspired to grab these so the first one
is I judge no one by David ly dusenberry
the next is Rec with power by David
Fitch and so with that in mind the title
of my message this week is power and
imitation power and imitation so uh last
week we named how uh Jesus maybe his
greatest Temptation uh was precisely the
the kind of um grabbing of political
power it's uh what a lot of people
around him wanted him to do I mean in
particular the disciples seem to be you
know kind of continually nudging him
that direction or not even nudging maybe
just assuming you know just like well of
course we can't wait for that moment
where you seize power and we your
right-hand men you know like there was
like they're just assuming this is how
it's going to go and uh oh good catch
there um you got that AC it is a blowing
I'm chill chill I don't know about y'all
I'm a baby when it comes to cold though
so maybe some of you are like finally it
feels good in here that's Jesse's in the
back he's like yes um
so yeah so you kind of see this pattern
all throughout the gospels um of of
people sort of wanting Jesus it's not
even just about like pure politics you
know it's really just sort of inviting
Jesus to play the kind of Earthly judge
decider um ruler and also you know more
political kind of King role and over and
over he just keeps refusing so last week
we looked at two passages um in
particular uh both of them a chapter 8
so Mark 8 and Matthew 8 and uh in in
Mark 8 basically there's this moment
where Jesus is explaining to his
disciples that he is headed to Jerusalem
which to them this is a good start like
yes go on Jesus and he's like and there
I shall be crucified and they're
like okay but then I'll rise again you
know but it's still just it's not quite
the The Narrative Arc you know if it
were a movie this wasn't quite what they
were foreen and Peter takes him aside
and rebukes him and Jesus tells him get
behind me
Satan like these strong words to Peter
like in other words he's seeing in kind
of Peter this sort of demonic Temptation
This this temptation to go to Jerusalem
and not give his life a ransom for many
but to grab
power so uh and then there's Matthew 8
which is the famous uh temptation of
Jesus by the devil and if you recall
that story The Very the third Temptation
for our purposes is like the most
important because that's where uh Jesus
or the devil offers Jesus all the
kingdoms of this
world and again uh he says in this
language this time it's not get behind
me but it's away from me Satan and he
again refuses so you see this kind of
pattern and I could go on in fact a very
early draft of this sermon had most of
it being just more examples but I
thought no I think the point's mostly
proven from last week but I'll just
quickly mention like just some other
little moments like so there's the the
story of the woman uh caught in adultery
from John chapter 8 where it's like a
very kind of public moment where they're
trying to get him to play kind of the
the role of Earthly judge right and he
steps out of the Trap it's like no I'm
not I'm not going there um refuses the
kind of um might say the way dusenberry
puts it is he refuses a political will
to judge right because in that it's a
temple state so for him to make a
religious judgment on this woman is at
the same time to make a political
judgment for her and he refuses to do
that but does retain his kind of right
to be the spiritual judge um need
something to hold this on probably not
sanitary
things thank you um oh just keeps trying
to escape so um yeah so that's kind of
yeah that's that's there's that story
from John 8 um then there's this little
moment in Luke 12 it's almost like a
little throwaway story might even
totally forget it but there's a moment
where a man comes up to Jesus and he's
having this dispute over over an
inheritance with his brother apparently
this is a tale's oldest time and he
comes to Jesus because he wants him to
like make a decision you know probably
in favor of him and Jesus is like what
why are you asking me to do this like no
I I'm not here to play this role for you
um instead he ends up guiding him
towards he said watch out for greed your
life doesn't consist in an abundance of
possessions you can see just a little
moment again where he's refusing to kind
of play this role and he he shifts it
towards a kind of different angle or
there's the the famous story um from
Mark 12 about the you know should we pay
the Roman Imperial tax and with this you
know coin with Caesar and he of course
famously says give to Caesar what is
Caesar's and give to God what is God's
so kind of again kind of sliding out
from making the Judgment um and and just
you can kind of see this play out I
think maybe the most um precent example
example though this is and this is our
text for today um is John 18:36 so this
is like the very moment Jesus is
literally standing before Pilate just
hours before his crucifixion when he
says this Jesus said my kingdom is not
of this world if it were my servants
would
fight to prevent my arrest by the judian
leaders but now my kingdom is from
another place
so that's going to be kind of our
meditation today is like what does that
mean exactly specifically that line my
kingdom is not of this
world like what does that mean I I don't
think Jesus is saying my kingdom has
nothing to do with this
world no it's not of it but I don't
think he's saying it doesn't have
anything to do with it I also don't
think he's
saying something like you know I don't
want my
perfect
spiritual Kingdom to get you know messy
from your kind of Earthly
political um evil kingdoms you know I
want to I want to retain the perfect
pure Kingdom not to be you know soiled
by your concerns you know your Earthly
worldly concerns I I don't I don't think
that's quite what he's getting at um I
think it's something kind of
deeper and that kind of leads us to our
big idea for today um which is this the
world
assumes an ontology of
violence Christ reveals an ontology of
peace I think that's actually what he's
getting at um
I know that's
like well ontology you know it's like
what is this it's like a classic Brett
word just throwing out this is
ridiculous you know um so we'll get into
it so um I mentioned last week at the
Jesus sees further than us and this is
an example of where I think he's he's
he's like he's playing uh a different
game than we're playing and um so an
ontology of
violence uh another word for violence
could just be for
coercion or Co coercion um and that word
though ontology means it's a
philosophical term it means um like it
has to do with being philosophers who
study ontology are asking questions
about being about existence so another
way to think of it is it's sort of
asking um like at root what is reality
about like what's what's real what's the
true story story of the
world and the The Way of the World the
kind of just working assumption that we
have honestly gleaned from hardfought
experience is that at its root the world
is it's just it's a place of
conflict like this is just how it is you
know I mean like there's winners and
there's losers it's it's it's kind of
it's an oppositional um dynamic IC at
work in the world you know if you win I
lose if you have I I
don't and so we kind of see this play
out I mean at every level think of even
business like capitalism is sort of a
way of playing this story out you know
where it's everyone's sort of against
everyone else we can't all win in the
same way you know and so reality becomes
this kind of it's conflictual in nature
reality is competitive it's ruthless
it's violent and because of this it is
of course it's all about power right
this is simply The Way of the World and
so we begin to think there is no
escaping this in other words we can talk
about like love and peace and you know
that's that's nice you know but at the
end of the day you know what I mean
that's like in in essence someone could
have an ontology of violence and and
still you know try to be good good and
like there's times for love and grace
and yeah sure sure sure
sure but at the end of the day you know
what I mean like it's when the rubber
meets the
road what's it
about it's about freaking winning you
know what I mean it's like this is just
and how are you GNA do that you're not
going to do it by being nice you know
what I mean like you're this not this is
not how the world works like that's
called
naivity you know just you're just being
naive so because there's no escaping
this politics just becomes this it's
like a continuation of this view you
know it's a it's a a war of sorts just
carried on by other means and we see
this every every day we watch the news
and you know I mean it's just bananas I
mean everyone it's just there's just
lies and you know it's almost just it
doesn't matter
what you say you know what I mean
because the point is just to win the
point is just to win whatever it takes
to win you just do it you know and
that's where generally it's tough like I
can't imagine trying to be like you're
like have you remember this video I
haven't seen this movie In Forever Mr
Smith Goes to Washington like where it's
like this guy with morals and ideals and
he wants to go to Washington like change
Washington you know what I mean and it's
just like oh my gosh like it just
doesn't work you can't no right because
at the end of the day like politics is
it's just it's
pragmatism you know you have like if you
have your ideals or your morals or your
you know whatever like you just get
eaten
alive and of course um I think honestly
if any sort of religious community
should kind of know this honestly it
should be Christians because
uh well precisely because of Jesus
interaction with the state and how all
this went down
right I mean pilate in the in the
gospels is like very a little hesitant
to crucify Christ because he's not he
doesn't totally get it like he realizes
this is kind of a there's a dispute
going on here you know and he can feel
himself being manipulated by certain
leaders and the mob and you know it's
like uh but so he but ultimately he
condemns
Jesus why because he's convinced of his
guilt no politics politics like it's
just
like you know there's even a line with
one of the um leaders where they say um
you know it's better that one man should
die than that the whole nation you know
basically suffer go under so you know
and that's why Christ is crucified like
it's it's sort of like it's that kind of
raw and real like it's just it's it's
it's political it's
pragmatic and so you get irony of all
ironies you know Jesus the one who kept
refusing political power is ultimately
um crucified as a political
criminal so what what does this kind of
mean for us um David dusenberry put it
in this way he said the freedom not to
resist
Caesar in the synoptic gospels generates
a freedom not to imitate him it's a
really key line there so what does he
mean by resist that's to the coercion
violence game in essence he's saying by
Jesus not um playing the Caesar game by
not resisting Caesar or pilate or those
leaders it opened up the space and the
freedom for him not to
imitate Caesar or pilate or these other
political leaders at the time um like in
other words maybe think of it like this
imagine if um
if Jesus said something like you know
what uh I am I I am the Son of God and I
have all the right ideas and so I'm
going to raise not a spiritual Army not
a metaphorical Army you know no no a
literal Army and and with that Army I'm
going to
establish a new
kingdom a new kingdom of love and peace
a pure Kingdom right a kingdom with
these new
values and of course you know you
do have to break a few eggs to make an
omelet so yes people will die but
ultimately in the end it will all be
worth
it can you see the problem there
where in essence Jesus ends up
reinforcing the very thing he set out to
undermine and in in essence he
reinforces the story of the world an
ontology of violence of force of
coercion by saying I want to do a new
thing I want to establish a new thing
you know but in essence you're not
you're not doing anything new you're
just reinforcing the old because of the
means because of the ways you go about
it right in essence he's just
establishing another Earthly violent
coercive Kingdom but this time in the
Name of
[Music]
Love and I think this is
um this is kind of what we can slip into
where we we too can feel like we we too
have to kind of fight by hook or by
crook by by any means
necessary but in that way we end up
getting caught caught up in this
ontology of violence this this way that
um ultimately can lead us to really uh
not so good places to put it mildly the
way David Fitch in his book Reckoning
with power put it he said kind of
reflecting on the modern church he said
the church seems prone to blurring the
powers in order to accomplish God's
justice we are ever tempted to take the
Reigns of top down coercive legislative
power
over to get God's work
done how do we learn from the mistakes
the white Evangelical Church has made as
it has capitulated to the evils of
slavery patriarchy and economic
exploitation every time it has aligned
itself with worldly power how do we
avoid making the same mistakes in
relation to social conflicts that plague
cultures today
uh JRR tolken in his trilogy The Lord of
the Rings is uh it's it's it's a story
about many things but perhaps above all
it's really a meditation on power uh for
those familiar with the story you know
there there is this ring this ring of
power and it offers its wearer uh
invisibility and immortality and for
those who know how to wield it uh like
unbelievable violent power coercive
power and and through a series of
circumstances though it's cut away from
its like original dark lord saaron and
it falls into the hands of those we
would call um the good good ones and uh
in many ways that's where the story kind
of begins because it also leads to a
debate because they have to um contend
with this question I think this is like
where the genius of the story and of
tolken really shines through they have
to wrestle with this question um which
is basically do we use the ring of
power and it's it's a stunning question
because there can be kind of a I know
like an initial like well of course well
of course you do right because that's in
essence what they want to do they ask do
we do we use the ring of power so that
we can defeat the forces of
evil right and abolish suffering from
the Earth
or is there something inherently sort of
corrupting about the ring
itself that's like the moral dilemma
that drives the story and this is where
the the kind of wisdom of certain
characters and this if you're familiar
with it this like uh elron and gadriel
and Gandalf is they discern even though
they're unbelievably powerful and they
know with that ring
no one could stand in their way they
know it but what do they
decide
no
no it needs to be
destroyed in fact there's this moment
where Frodo The Hobbit who's tasked to
like carry the ring to destroy it um
offers it to
Gandalf and uh this is Gandalf's
response he said I dare not take it not
even to keep it
safe understand froto I would use this
ring from a desire to do
good but through me it would wield a
power too great and terrible to
imagine now of course tolken never like
in interviews or anything never like
told us or reveal sort of like what what
did he think exactly the ring of power
was like how did it correspond to today
you know people have like speculated
like it's nuclear weapons you know um or
you know uh or political tyranny or
something that effect but I I think we
could say this though at the very least
um the the ring of power it's something
like a kind of top down
coercive
Force which no matter how much good you
put it
to only ever does what it just
reinforces
itself does that make sense you use the
the ring of power to force it but what
have you just
forced you've you've kind of you've
basically reinforced an ontology of
violence right like this is the way you
get things done this is just how the
world works and so like the one way I've
been thinking about there's this little
phrase uh and I I looked online to see
you originated this but I I don't know
who it was but it was um what you win
them with is what you win them
to in other words how you get victory
also communicates and reinforces itself
you know what I mean because it's
because the losers so to speak the
losers say like ah well that's what we
need to do you know what I mean so so in
essence whatever works whatever you win
them with you also make converts to
precisely that way and you can see where
this becomes a real problem with
violence and such because what you beat
them with they say ah that was our
problem we didn't have enough of
that and you can see our world today
where it's this sort of ongoing problem
ever reinforcing it
itself and uh here's the good news
though I know this can all be a little
bit heavy um I think the good news is
that Christ actually does in in refusing
that
power actually does open up a new
way actually says you know what the
world at its
roots is not just violence and
competition and ruthlessness all the way
down no if you go down to Rock Bottom
down to the deepest depths of ontology
down into being itself really that what
you find there is God and God is love
and God is
peace this is actually the truth of the
world on its surface you may not see it
of course and we don't a lot I mean it
breaks through we see
moments but if you go down and sink into
the depths of God there you find this
ontology of Peace this new way and so
what is it to be Christian it's to align
ourselves with Christ with his
way his way of
being the way that refuses to grab and
force and um
compel and instead just continually as
best we
can continues to choose the way of great
love continues to bear with people to be
patient with people to do our best to
work with people rather than saying
saying I give up on you and we got to do
something about you know and we keep
working with since of course this is
exactly what Christ did with
us you
see what you win them with is what you
win them
to and so when you win someone with
patient persistent unconditional love
what have you won them
to patient
resistent unconditional
love you have shown them there is a
better way the way of Christ the way of
great
love so in closing I want to read a very
uh very ancient but very powerful prayer
written by St Francis of a CCE and if
you're open to it I invite you to close
your eyes so I can read this prayer over
you so that an ontology of Peace can
begin to to seep into our
bones Lord make me an instrument of your
peace where there is
hatred let me so
love where there is injury
pardon where there is
doubt
Faith where there is
despair hope where there is Darkness
light and where there is sadness
Joy oh Divine Master grant that I may
not so much seek to be
consoled as to
console to be understood as to
understand to be loved as to
love for it is in giving that we receive
it is in pardoning that we are pardoned
and it is in dying that we are born to
eternal
life in the name of the Father the Son
holy spirit
amen so on the night Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples and at that meal he held up a
loaf of bread and he broke it and he
said this is my body broken for you and
then he held up a cup of wine he said
this is my blood shed for you whenever
you eat this bread whenever you drink
this cup remember me so as we come to
the table of the Lord tonight as we take
in the body of Christ in the bread the
blood of Christ in the wine may we take
in Christ in his way may that ontology
of Peace begin to seep into our very
bones so the way we'll participate
tonight we'll just go row by row
starting here in the front and working
our way back we'll form just one row
right here in the middle uh we practice
what's called an open table so if you're
here tonight and you want to participate
um then you are welcome to do that
regardless of your like denomination or
exact theological beliefs or whatever if
something in you wants to connect with
Christ then you come forward and uh and
do that you should know the red is wine
and the white is H grape juice and then
finally you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like some folks like
to come and kneel at the front some
return to their chairs to partake um or
just take immediately but you just do it
however you want no one will lead you
through the exact moment of partaking so
this is the table not at the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so come you who
have much faith and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
service with a song that is quite um
old It Was Written um I think early 90s
maybe and um but it's one that is stuck
in my head on a regular basis because
the lyrics of it um I feel like paint
such a beautiful picture of what we were
talking about tonight and just the type
of leadership that Jesus chose in
sacrificial love and uh cruciform love
and um so we wanted to just hearken back
to that tonight to close our service
with and if you guys want to stand with
us and sing it or sit that's fine either
way but um it might might be new to this
community and we just invite you to join
in as you can so
[Music]
oh kneel me
down
again here at your
feet show me how much you
love human
[Music]
oh
Spirit be the
star that leads me
to The
Humble Heart of
Love I see in you
cuzz you are the
god of the
broen the
friend of the
we you wash the
feet of the
wey
embrace the ones in
need and I want to be just like you
Jesus to have this heart in
me you are the
god of the
humble you are the
[Music]
humble oh he me down
again here at your
[Music]
feet show me how much you
love
[Music]
humil oh
Spirit be the the
star that leads me
to The
Humble Heart of
Love I
see in
you cuz you are the
god of the RO
Bren the
friend of the
we you wash the
feet of the
wey
embrace the ones in
need and I want to be just like you
Jesus to have have this heart in
me you are the
god of the
humble you are the
humble
King you are the
god of
the you are the humble
[Music]
thank you guys so much
um this was really encouraging for me
I've been very anxious um over the past
few months um I'm a public school
teacher and I'm wearing merch for drag
queen so you can probably guess how I'm
feeling about the election um I believe
in using your voice to Advocate um and
this was also a fantastic reminder to be
peace to the people in front of me and
to love them regardless of what is going
to happen um so thank you so much again
for joining us um this evening if you're
new we would love for you to fill out a
card at the table on your way out or you
can scan the QR code um just so we can
say thanks for being here um or answer
any questions you may have about what
this community looks like um we can all
use more uh relational support and
spiritual connection and a way that we
do that at the table is through meetups
if you're not yet part of a Meetup you
can scan the QR code um to find one that
works for you um generosity is a key
aspect of a life of adoration and
worship if you call the table home um we
invite you to scan the QR code and
consider um giving financially to
support the work that's done here
um and now I'm going to send you into
your week with this blessing you can
hold your hands out to receive it um or
you can just open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day so as you go
into your week ahead with it's yet to be
determined and highs and
lows go filled with the assurance that
you are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed and we'll see
you next Sunday thank you
[Music]
cuz you are the
god of the
broken the friend of the
we you wash the
feet of the
wey embrace the ones in me
and I want to be just like you
Jesus to have this heart in
me you are the
god of
the you are the
[Music]
hum you are the god
of
the you are the